so
the paper that i proposed for the
conference
as these things will often turn out to
be
didn't get completely finished there's
still a fifth part to it to be written
there's a lot of footnotes to be added
and the paper's grown far too long
to adequately read within the time
allotted and still have time for
questions so i'm actually going to
only read from the first three parts
the fourth part actually deals with
aquinas's appropriation of anselm so we
can talk about that if we want to
in the q a but i'm
particularly interested in sort of
inserting anselm into
mcintyre's account so
and after virtue's aptly titled chapter
13 medieval aspects and occasions
aleister mcintyre passes over one
medieval thinker a philosopher and
theologian of arguably the first rank
namely anselm of canterbury he does
discuss the scholastic doctor usually in
passing in a few earlier and several
later works but there is relatively
little engagement of this innovative
benedictine thinker
even in his recent god philosophy
universities anselm's contributions to
the catholic philosophical tradition
are relegated to a chapter lumping him
in with boethius and pseudo-theonisis
although mcintyre includes him in
several auditory listings
as a member of an ongoing intellectual
tradition the analysis that he provides
of ensembian themes is entirely confined
to
faith-seeking understanding of the
so-called ontological argument
easily lending the impression that ansel
made little or no
additional contributions to the catholic
philosophical tradition
in particular to moral inquiry
in actuality anselm's role scope and
influence has been considerably greater
not least in the domain of moral inquiry
theory and practice now my goal here is
not to criticize mcintyre
but rather to supplement his accounts
i'm not saying that you know after
virtue should have been like 3 000 pages
long you know everybody who
you know should have been inserted in
their git gets their place i mean
you know he's telling a particular story
with certain key points
what i want to do is supplement his
account by inserting a fuller account of
anselm's thought practice and influence
into mcintyre's account of medieval
moral theory and inquiry
so bring anselm into conversation with
and to some degree illuminated by
mcintyre's concepts and concerns i'd
like to make it clear from the start
that my argument here
to use some common medieval categories
is not one grounded on necessitas
but rather convenient conveniencia often
translated as befitting-ness
but here perhaps understood better as
greater adequacy and intelligibility
put in other terms i'm not claiming that
mcintyre need of engaged ansel in order
to make his own
master arguments but rather it would
have been better more befitting
resulting in a richer more robust
narrative of medieval thought
had he done so so the paper as it's
intended had five sections four which
are written
in the first i review mcintyre's
explicit reference to and discussions of
anselm as
a medieval christian thinker in the
second i discuss how anselm fits into
the augustinian tradition of moral
inquiry as mcintyre articulates it and
the third i turn
to anselm himself setting out seven key
features of his moral theory
i'm only going to cover six here
actually though leading up to discussing
his views on virtue and vice
and the fourth part i discuss aquinas is
engagements of anselm and in the fifth i
discuss his wider
influence in medieval thought
so the first part if we view mcintyre's
works from after virtue on as
representing an
ongoing contributions to an overarching
project something that i take is
uncontroversial here
if we focus specifically on his
discussions of anselm
a progressive deepening of appreciation
becomes apparent
anselm goes unmentioned and after virtue
but gets a brief mention in who's
justice which rationality where he says
the late 11th and 12th century european
culture was one in which philosophical
inquiry was largely unsystematic and
theological
studies largely on philosophical there
were of course
exceptional philosophical figures such
as anselm and
abellard there he's saying something
that you know hegel is
the same as well mcintyre however
concludes there the intellectual climate
and generations following is better
represented by john salisbury
anselm receives somewhat more
substantive discussion in three rival
versions
the first occurs in the context of the
problem of different and rival
augustinian epistemologies
mcintyre writes it is then in the
inescapably universal application of the
concept of perfection that god has
universally acknowledged
an acknowledgment of which an
acknowledgement which
and some transform into an argument an
argument that from the assertion of the
existence
within the mind of that then which no
operator can be conceived it follows
then that that
that then which not no greater can be
conceived also exists
outside the mind anselm's arguments
mcintyre continues are in no way
accidentally in the form of prayer
to understand the required concept
adequately the mind must already be
directed by faith
towards its true perfection the rational
justification of belief in the object of
faith is internal for the life of faith
so that's the
big reference later when articulating
the relationship between
inquiry and accountability and arguing
that truth must be more than warranted
assertability mcintyre notes
to be accountable in and for inquiry is
to be open to having to give an account
of what
one is either said or done and then to
having to amplify
explain defend and if necessary either
modify or abandon that account
and this latter case to begin the work
of supplying a new one
socrates plato and aristotle
invented and perfected a dialectical
mode of accountability
the bible and augustinianism a
confessional
and some moved from confession to
dialectic aquinas both from confession
to dialectic and from dialectic
to confession mcintyre makes one other
less specific reference to anselm in
that work as well when discussing what
he takes to be a 14th and 15th century
genesis of the institution of academic
philosophy
he tells us it is always salutary to
remember that most of the history of
philosophy has occurred outside of the
history of that
particular professionalized institution
and he talks about augustine anselm
avalart and aquinas lumping all the a's
in pretty much
defined their activities in terms of a
very different conception of inquiry
which they they
you know could have called philosophy
and some of them in fact did
ansem is also referenced in two essays
in the tasks of philosophy
the more substantive one occurs in first
principles final ends contemporary
issues focusing on aquinas's conception
of truth
in which aquinas cites anselm and
augustine among others and he says
the complexity of aquinas's view is a
consequence of his having integrated
into a single
single account theses from both
aristotle
and islamic and jewish commentary upon
aristotle and from augustine and anselm
perhaps the most sustained engagement of
anselm on mcintyre's part occurs in the
recent god philosophy universities a
selective history of the catholic
philosophical tradition
where he devotes roughly four pages
rather than mere paragraphs to handsome
unfortunately sticking to the most part
to discussing anselm's so-called
ontological argument
and i'll only cite the one passage from
that text which gets beyond that
particular concern
mcintyre says using the word philosopher
as we use it now we may say a bandsaw
that he was that he was a philosopher
mal grey louis
despite himself as well as a
dialectician and theologian he took
himself to be
what is true of anselm is true also of
all those who had done their
philosophical work
in the augustinian tradition and indeed
all of their patristic predecessors
in one important way they were therefore
not contributing to the catholic
philosophical tradition
that is to a tradition within which a
catholic allegiance is inseparable from
a recognition of philosophical inquiry
as a secular
autonomous activity and tradition yet in
another way they made a major
contribution to that tradition
for when it finally emerged from the
13th century
those who founded it drew heavily on the
augustinian and patristic philosophical
resources provided by the theology
into which they were educated a few
remarks on mcintyre's account of anselm
are in order
first within this narrative anselm
resides entirely within the confines of
the augustinian tradition
as mcintyre has construed it second the
main interest anselm presents is as a
main representative of that tradition
and as a source thomas aquinas engaged
as an interlocutor
assimilating important contributions
from anselm's thought abandoning the
inadequate or relevant
detritus of the remainder of his works
third the ontological argument accepted
these contributions are confined almost
entirely epistemological
concerns the connections between faith
reason and practice on the one hand
and the nature of truth on the other
mcintyre's account
strikes one as an assessment one might
reasonably make of hanson's thought if a
person were to focus
principle principally on the prosologion
and on a certain set of thomas aquinas
references to anselm
in certain respects it appears eminently
modern redolent to the very problematic
macintosh on
critiques a retention of philosophical
vocabulary narratives and figures
coupled with a
self-unaware lack of understanding of
these rooted in a disconnect from the
matrices of practice theory and
tradition
at the very least this account can be
faulted for not doing justice to the
ansem
we know not only through his own text
but through the effects his thought
exerted on medieval thought
and practice so i'm going to skip ahead
a little bit
and ask how does the ensemble fit within
the augustinian tradition as mcintyre
depicts it and works
like after virtue who's justice and
three rival versions i'm skipping over
the discussion of anselm's a paradoxical
figure in his own right just to focus on
the augustinian
aspect that mcintyre is working out so
in some respects
anselm perhaps appears to diverge from
from central problematics or disputes
distinctive to that tradition
although he's interested in text and
teaching he rarely cites other
authorities belonging to his own
tradition
and even in treatises which pertain to
the study of sacred scripture in his own
words he
his emphasis is placed almost entirely
on employing reasons resources to better
understand subjects not only raised by
scriptural passages
but also problematic or puzzling and
moral life
he also seems rather uninterested in the
master metaphor of the world is text
anselm is to be sure a christian
platonus indebted to augustine
but draws very infrequently upon imagery
of illumination
as compared for exa for example to the
augustinian focus on developing memory
or mindfulness
understanding and love this three-part
thing
he arguably sidesteps what mcintyre
calls the apparent contradiction at the
heart of the augustinian account of
knowledge
it's not to say that he resolves it he
doesn't deal with it at all
so maybe he's not an augustinian man in
many other respects anselm is a figure
right at the center of this augustinian
tradition of moral inquiry
his works are indeed intended as
vehicles for argumentation
intelligible to non-christians for
example in the case of kurdish homo
where
anselm both both credits holy fathers
and teachers for presenting the
rationality of our faith
for refuting the foolishness and
breaking the obtuseness of infidels and
for nourishing those who with hearts
already cleansed by faith delight in the
rationality of that faith
and then explicitly adopts it as his
project
at the same time some practical
commitment to christian faith in life
some degree of intellectual and also
volitional development
at the very least some openness will be
required
in order for that rationality to be
progressively more adequately
grasped by the reader
skipping down a little bit and some
texts make demands and claims upon their
readers involving the kind of trust
mcintyre identifies particularly with
augustinian tradition
this offers the opportunity for ansem's
works to become to some extent as
mcintyre calls them
texts in which such a person discovery
discovers the story of him or herself
including the story of how he or she was
transformed into a reader of these texts
that's how he
describes the scriptural texts and also
attacks within the augustinian tradition
such a personal narrative is then
revealed as located within yet more
encompassing narratives which impose
their own demands on both the person's
intellect and their will
as the condition for uncovering fuller
intelligibility and mcintyre
continues by saying that history is a
movement towards the truth becoming
manifest a movement towards
intelligibility
but in the course of discovering the
intelligibility of the order of things
we also discover
why at different stages greater or
lesser degrees of intelligibility
remain so that's you know pretty typical
uh i think everybody here is familiar
with mcintyre's you know
reading of the augustinian tradition in
that part another key
aspect is the will mcintyre following a
number of other scholars credits
augustine with the discovery of the will
as such as a faculty
capable not only of determination of
other faculties or parts of a human
being but is radically
self-determinative
setting aside controversies whether
augustine really discovered or invented
the will of the faculty
it would be more accurate to say that
augustine provided a definitive
and fruitful articulation of the concept
of will
one more adequately corresponding to the
reality we encounter within and without
ourselves if we look at mcintyre's
characterizations of augustine's
insights
anselm is again recognizably augustinian
mcintyre says the difference between
augustine and his classical as opposed
to his new testament predecessors can be
described in two closely related ways
the first concerns how the failure of
how someone who knows what it is best
for him or her to do but nonetheless
does not act accordingly is to be
explained
augustine holds that it is possible for
someone to know what it is best to do
with a particular situation
and for there to be no defect in the
passions and such
except that they're misdirected by the
will the will being anterior to reason
has as it at most at its most
fundamental level no reason for its
biddings
for augustine intellect itself is the
second way intellect itself needs to be
moved to activity by the will
the human will is then the ultimate
determinant of human action and the
human will is systematically misdirected
and misdirected in such a way that it is
not within its power to
redirect itself two important
corollaries
of this perspective also get discussed
by mcintyre the first has to do with
affectivity desire and love
he says our desires need to be directed
towards objects other than those to
which we
first find them directed and ordered
hierarchically
the direction and ordering of human
desires is the work of the will
and because human desires are in
whatever state they are in because of
either the direction of or the failure
to direct the will
human desire is unlike the desires of
other animals are voluntary
the second has to do with justice the
virtues and in particular with the
virtue of humility
mcintyre writes the fundamental human
virtue is a virtue of the will in its
returning to freedom just as the
fundamental human vice is the vice of
the will
in its self-enslaved condition the
fundamental human vice is of course
pride correspondingly the fundamental
human virtue is humility
justice therefore cannot inform an
individual's character unless that
character is also informed by humility
and the rootedness of justice and pride
entails
the rudeness of injustice sorry in pride
entails that injustice consists in
disobedience
so all of this is is you know fairly
standard reading of the
augustinian tradition which in which
aquinas is supposed to
you know synthesized and assimilated
mcintyre expands what he calls the
augustinian tradition to encompass two
other faithful developments within
medieval thought and practice and he'd
have to do this
if he wants to say that everything is
augustinian because obviously not
everybody
was you know a follower of augustine in
that sense
so these two faithful developments are
the ongoing project of monastic and in
particular benedictine life
and the complex interactions between
church and state and medieval politics
and culture
anselm was both formed and formative
in both of these developments mcintyre
notes
it was because intellectual inquiry in
the augustinian mode is conceived as a
progress towards perfection
through an ever more adequate
apprehension of perfection that
theoretical inquiry
and practical inquiry were so closely
inter
interrelated he goes on to point out
that the disciplines of monastic
life more especially those of
reformations of monastic life in which
the rule of saint benedict had been
reestablished provided a religious ideal
one which provided a practical analog
and quite arguably
fertile soil for augustinian moral
inquiry
so mcintyre actually says the rule of
saint benedict's practical theology
presupposes
what saint augustine had affirmed that
it is only through the transformation of
the will from a state of pride
to one of humility that the intelligence
can be rightly directed
will is more fundamental than
intelligence and thinking undirected by
will uninformed by humility will always
be apt to go astray
as a spiritual director and as avid
uh prior and finally archbishop anselm
also finds himself drawn both willingly
and unwillingly directly into the wake
of the second development mcintyre
describes in which
uh mcintyre's words the realization of
the institutional and other practical
implications of the augustinian
standpoint was achieved
often enough by those who were not
themselves theorists except in an ad hoc
manner in the course of debates and
struggles over practical issues but
whose words and actions emerge from a
background of belief structure by
augustine's
theology gregory vii through gregory the
great
was the figure who mcintyre singles out
discussing how he
quote articulated as political theology
in the course of discharging four
distinct but related people
responsibilities
and anselm was actually deeply involved
in three of these as sort of a
inheritor of this problematic he didn't
deal with with gregory
he dealt with later popes in his role as
archbishop of canterbury
so you know the three that he dealt with
were internal reform of the church
to read his letters constant problems
all sorts of problems going on
as a matter of fact anybody who's
tempted to critique the the
church you know in whatever sense at any
given time
really want to read you know some of the
letters these these uh spiritual
directors and bishops
wrote back you know centuries before and
just find out just how bad things were
that
you know so internal reform of the
church affirming the order of eustintia
justice against ostensibly christian
rulers anselm
had to be exiled from england twice for
opposing the
norman king of england one of the you
know
people trying to direct one of the
nascent nation states
and then finally a formation of the
principles of justice
so mcintyre is giving us a picture just
to
sum up a little bit here he's giving us
a picture of the augustinian
heritage that's very robust attentive to
the interrelation between theory
practice and some of those practices
include
things like prayer you know engaging in
memorizing the salt or you know all
sorts of things along those lines
and and some although mcintyre doesn't
tell you this anselm fits right smack
dab into the middle of all that if
all tanks is you know reading through
the say the life of saint hanselm or
reading through some of his works and
letters and you see how he fits into
this matrix
in the third section which i'm going to
hit on now i'm uh
looking at how anselm himself reworks
augustinian
monastic moral theory so i'm not going
to try to provide a comprehensive or
even
adequately detailed exposition of his
moral theory
this requires an effort of integrating
numerous discussions from this corpus as
a whole
a task i'm undertaking in the monograph
i'm writing on the subject at
present instead i'm going to discuss uh
originally seven down to six key
connected themes worked out in anselm's
moral
theory prior to that though i would like
to point out one central and often
overlooked feature
of anselm's thought which integrates his
moral theory
into his broader project of
faith-seeking understanding
and it's good to begin from the formula
anselm's develop anselm develops and
uses in the work that mcintyre does
reference the prosyllogium which we're
all familiar with because we've all had
to teach the ontological argument at one
time
and hopefully use primary texts
the login starts from this that then
which nothing greater can be thought
right now several things need to be
noted
first anselm uses this formula to
develop a single argument as he called
an unomar argumentum
running through nearly the entirety of
the pro syllogium
an argument intended not only to prove
that god truly exists
but equally and these are anselm's words
that god is the supreme good needing no
other good and that all others need so
that they might
be and be well and quote whatever else
we believe about the divine substance
so moral theory adequately worked out
will be inextricably connected with the
metaphysics and epistemology orienting
the human created being to god
for hansel second anselm not only
explicitly uses this language of that
then which nothing greater can be
thought in other words which are much
more
closely focused on moral philosophy like
the day veritate or the courteous homo
he consistently employs and uncovers the
logic implicitly involved in this
conception
which calls the human being both to use
and to improve
all of its resources of reason and will
in order to more and more adequately
understand not only god
but the nature and condition of human
being the contours interrelations of
truth and justice
and the complex and faithful
interactions between divine grace and
even free will all of that is there in
this formula
and so you know seeing it as postcard
the ontological argument or a tiny piece
of the ontological argument really
obscures the
picture so the
first thing modalities of
study truth anselm's moral theory really
must begin with his treaty to stay very
tightly around truth
there beginning from analysis the most
easily understood experience of truth
and signification he goes on to analyze
truth and thinking
including reasoning and truth and sense
perception and judgment
if he stopped with these his theory of
truth would not be particularly
interesting but he also examines truth
and several other modalities
these include truth in the will truth in
action
truth in the being of things and the
supreme truth that is god
in which all other truth participates as
john whipple points out in a passage
judiciously cited by christopher lott's
inclusion of certain of these dimensions
places handsome in a
general tradition regarding the nature
of truth one including not only
augustine
but also later david cena one heavily
neoplatonic as he calls it emphasizing
the truth of being
this tradition is then at odds with a
more aristotelian conception that
stresses truth is an adequation of mind
and reality or truth of the intellect
anselm however makes several additional
moves not least of which is insisting
that there is truth and falsity
in the will and in action not in a
merely analogous sense
but actually originally he is able to do
this precisely because he comes to
understand truth as rectitudo
rightness what is the case when
something is as it ought to be
or does what it ought to or when
something does what it was made in order
to do
so within a teleological scheme right
but he used teleology as built into the
fabric of creative reality
second anselm distinguishes between the
two between two types of truth one which
something possesses when it conforms to
this norm
which can be or not be in a deeper sort
of truth inalienable
from what bears or is conditioned by
that truth third anselm notes the
interconnections between these different
mentalities of truth even signification
and thinking are actually within the
realm of action
and can be judged accordingly an action
in its turn at least for rational beings
depends on the will
actions and volitions even the very
truth even the very being of a thing in
turn
are also significative and can be judged
according to the truth of what it is
they seem to claim
state betray or presuppose so that's one
important aspect of this moral theory
the second one is justice as rectitude
of will
as anselm understands it justice is at
its very heart a configuration of truth
in on truth he introduces the formula
that will run throughout his works
justice is rightness of will but it is
not simply any rightness of will
any case of the will conforming to what
is right willing what one ought to
he introduces a further qualification
which both injects a kind of
self-referentiality and stresses motive
and mindset justice's rightness of will
kept for its own sake as anselm notes
a volition does not merely have an
object of what but also a subjective
motive of why
there can be truth in the will when a
person wills what they ought to but this
is not yet distinctively human moral
goodness that is justice
unless they will what they ought to for
the right reason at the very least
implicitly because it is the right thing
to will and because thereby they
maintain that very justice within the
will is a valuable good
what he's doing there is is you know
it's not to say that this is completely
radically new that
a lot of this can't be found in
augustine but he's taking augustinian
doctrine
and really crystallizing it laying out
the contours in ways that are
quite precise four other things need to
be noted about anselm's conception of
justice
first it admits of degrees it's possible
for a person to be more or less just and
it's possible for one's determinant
willing to be more or less justice not
just an off on switch
second injustice is funnily
fundamentally the privation of justice
which ought to be present in the
person's will
moral evil and injustice is not
something determinate on its own
but rather something parasitical upon
being goodness and justice
third although it's not possible for a
human being to be entirely unjust and
even given that there are degrees of
justice and injustice
there is a threshold above which a
person is just and possesses justice
below which a person is unjust and is
deprived of justice
fourth while justice and injustice can
rightly be said and judged at
all sorts of things including actions
persons states of affairs relationships
or policies
in every case ransom is very very clear
about this says this many times
in every case those justices or
injustices derive ultimately from a just
or unjust
will so justice is completely connected
with the
will so let's look at the third thing
now which is his analysis of the will
one key need for moral theory and some
discern was providing
an account to the very structure of the
will it's just noted in on truth about
determinate acts of volition he uses the
familiar distinction between subjective
motive and the object of the will
and discussed how an action or volition
could be both right and wrong at the
same time depending on
which perspective you're looking at i
also i don't have it in here but he
also focused a great amount on on
the need to develop what we would call
in contemporary terms adequate
descriptions of
adequate descriptions and moral language
of what's actually going on
what thomas aquinas calls the moral
species of an act right
in on freedom of choice anselm explains
how a person can be willing and
unwilling in the same situation
he also distinguishes between freedom of
the will and its first sense
is the ability to keep justice for its
own sake when one possesses it
and a more common but defective
understanding of freedom the freedom to
do what one wills
whether it be good or bad more most
importantly he begins to elaborate a
tripartite distinction about the will
itself between the will is instrument
the faculty of will
the will is use and the will is
inclination
by means of this distinction he's able
to lend additional intelligibility to
phenomena like weakness of will and
temptation
discordance within the will resolution
and perseverance
responsibilities people bear for
inclinations and habits the connection
between free will and rationality
and even interactions between divine
grace and human choice
in on the fall the devil he further
develops his account of will by
explicitly distinguishing between two
fundamental inclinations of the will
one of these inclinations is the will to
happiness which every sentient being
possesses
the basics this basic structure of the
will directs us towards the goods we
judge to be beneficial or commodum
is the latin term to us and away from
evils which we judge to be harmful
providing us with a structure of
motivation and desire that not only
inclines the will and involves the
intellect
and will indeterminate situations but
also comes to take on lasting habitual
developed patterns and orientations
the other fundamental inclination is the
will to justice
this differs from the will to happiness
in several important ways
unlike the will to happiness the will to
justice which is in fact the state of
justice within the will
can be lost this occurs when a person
willingly abandons their will to justice
by preferring something else to the
justice which that person wants to
instead keep
another important difference is that
whereas the will to happiness is not
itself happiness
its own object but rather desires
pursues and chooses what conduces to
happiness
the world of justice actually is that
very justice
to will justice is to choose to keep it
to resist temptations to abandon it to
value it above all other lesser goods
it requires that the person will justice
act out of justice love and desire
justice and cultivate that state of
justice within him or herself
i should also put in there they need to
also understand
what justice consists in another
important difference is that the will of
justice is supposed to moderate
and regulate to introduce greater
rationality to the will to happiness
which in a fallen creature is liable to
lead
one into injustice lastly once lost
this is for anselm the will of justice
although the person can regret its loss
and can desire it cannot be restored
solely by the will of that person
it requires cooperation between the
willing person and divine grace
which is the section that i pass over
next so that will remain
you know murky and mysterious as grace
often is right
let's move on now to pride self-will and
humility this is another central
uh conception not only in the
augustinian
tradition but particularly for insult
the most difficult fundamental and
enduring obstacle for human
beings and accepting preserving and
willing in accordance with justice in
anselm's view is the vice of pride
a radically disordered moral and
intellectual condition which generates
an obscuring or inversion of right
apprehension
of moral values in the human person the
term that anselm actually uses more
often than superbia
which is you know the typical word for
pride which gets to the very heart of
what he understands it to be as
propriovolent
which can be translated as one's own
will or as
autonomous willing none of these are
particularly great translations to get
across what he's
getting and in the paper i talk about
how he doesn't come up with this term
but he's he's again transforming it it's
used by
benedict of nursia by the uh
the anonymous master who wrote the rule
before benedict augustine jerome john
cassian
but anselm is doing something a little
bit more developed with it
anselm provides additional precision
required for its centrality and its
moral theory
pride's promise is that the creature can
determine its own will entirely or even
just essentially on its own basis
setting itself above the normativity
built into the very fabric of creative
being to follow pride even in the name
of some conception of justice
inevitably entails abandoning justice
within the will
and paradoxically it does not bring
freedom to the would-be autonomous being
but rather subjugation is something else
a lowering not only of the being and its
dignity
but even in the manifold of its desires
in terms of the two fundamental
inclinations of the will pride
inevitably
requires abandoning justice becoming
thereby subjected not only to outside
forces
but also to one's own appetites and the
disordered will to happiness
while obedience is strictly speaking the
opposite of pride is self-will
but most counters the vice of pride is
the virtue of humility
anselm both practices and preaches the
conceptions of this virtue
set out by other earlier members of this
tradition and makes new contributions of
his own treating the virtue most
explicitly
in the day similar to the news some of
which most of which is anselmian
there's a bit of detritus in that text
which is why it you know it doesn't get
included in the ensembium corpus
that other people snuck in you know one
of the side effects of becoming somebody
famous
in the middle ages is other people would
write stuff and stick it under your name
so the day simultaneous acquired not in
selmium parts but but the parts on
humility are definitely
at least the textual interpreters think
and selma
anselm devotes considerable discussion
humility in that work about a few of
them
about which a few remarks are going to
have to suffice here
first using the similitude of a mountain
anselm sets out for
seven progressive degrees of humility
and accounts supplementary to saint
benedict's own 12-run ladder of humility
which thomas aquinas realizes when he
considers that very question
of the sequence acunda discussing
humility right
anselm and benedict's accounts actually
compatible
second humility does not consist of
basing or devaluing oneself
but in attempting to understand and
enact one's own proper value
in relation to other beings and god
third it is humility according to
handsome that not only reflects but
actually provides a person with adequate
self-understanding
um kagnitziosui fourth humility is
required as a basis for the other
virtues
this does not mean of course that before
other virtues can be developed or vices
rooted out
one must previously have ascended all
the levels of humility
but rather the person have and
concretely choose the right volitional
vector and orientation in order for
those virtues to be more and more
adequately understood and cultivated
what time what time do we go to uh we go
to a quarter after right
three three three all right i am going
to skip the
the section on on concord or or uh
harmony and just jump to the part on the
virtues and
vices though according to admirer
one of his close friends and biographers
and some uncovered the origins and so to
speak the very seeds and roots and
processes of growth of all virtues and
vices
and made it clearer than day making it
clearer than day
they like how the former could be
attained in the latter avoided or
subdued
unfortunately for us anselm never
authored a treatise on the virtues of
such
and it appears that his teaching on the
virtues and vices was largely carried
out in oral form
what we do possess are a number of
scattered discussions and references
which can nevertheless be drawn together
allowing us to systematically
reconstruct at least outlines of
anselm's teaching
he holds that the virtues are in their
full sense as good mores qualities of
the soul which were unstable
now brought to the condition of habit
they exist in the soul as stable
correspondingly vices in the full sense
likewise have rooted themselves within
the soul and particularly within the
will
of the person who's suffering from them
anselm also speaks of the virtues and
vices in a more encompassing manner in
which they signify wider identical
identifiable patterns of behavior desire
willing
noting for example that within
christendom as he says certain people
are strong in the virtues but many are
weak
he tells us it is not so often as one
does the work of virtue or vice
that a person is properly said to have
virtue or vice itself
for it's insofar as one has them then
when
they are possessed from habituation that
human beings are said to be just or
vicious so he's got a fairly well
developed conception of virtue it's not
you know departing radically from from
other people talking about it
anselm regards virtues and vices in the
wider sense as opposite ends of the
threshold
and that in the stricter senses
consolidation is further opposed to each
other
and more distant from that threshold the
human will
in the sense of will is use determinate
acts of will
will indeterminate occasions is poised
upon and can cross that threshold
between
these in fact anselm frames the human
will at least in many circumstances
is continuously poised between willing
justice or willing injustice
when the person's will is properly
aligned by right use of its own capacity
for self-determination he tells us
the soul is open to the inclination of
the virtues and to willing what should
be preferred
memory to remembering what ought to be
remembered he goes on all these
twos he says the mind is raised up to
charity is disposed of humility is
strengthened towards patience and is
open to the other virtues that should be
generated
choosing wrongly willingly succumbing to
temptation sets one instead on the path
of the vices and produces a will
deprived of justice turned against
itself subject to the effects of its own
privation
anselm starkly draws the lines between
these two alternatives and lays out the
resources for the will's right guidance
he says god suggests
reason suggests virtue suggests that i
live rightly
and that within me is the material
within which i can do that if i will
opposing this or the devil the carnal
appetites and devices
to which one might also have things that
ansel talks about bad reasonings actions
and the examples of other person
giving into these deforms the will
darkens the intellect eventually
admiring the vicious person within a
condition from which they cannot
extricate themselves without aid
anselm depicts the virtues not only as
not only as habitual states of willing
desiring and acting in a person's soul
inclinations towards what is right that
actively
uh provide guidance to the person in
fact they are essential to the
functioning of reason itself
in practical context he says just as the
human body cannot subsist without
frequent provision of food to it
so the soul cannot live with by a reason
without frequent engagement with the
virtues they require acknowledgement of
and steer us towards deeper
collaboration of our free will
with divine grace ransom and anselm
criticizes certain prideful people as he
calls them who judge that the entire
efficacy of the virtues resides in the
pre-choice of the will alone
in fact as he and counsels in numerous
letters in his treatises we're called
upon to continually improve what measure
of the virtues we possess at any time
and i'm going to skip over some of these
uh many references
where he's telling people that they have
to do that
he also says that we have to we have to
develop a capacity for perseverance
within the world for resisting the
temptation to choose goods incompatible
with justice a kind of fortitude he uses
that term
consisting in willing perseveringly
indeed and here's where i'm going to
finish indeed fortitude encourages
anselm understands
it understands it ranks among the
archetectonic virtues
those most integral to practical life
and moral inquiry
noting this provides a good occasion to
bring these outlines to his moral theory
his outlines of his moral theory to
close by making a comparison between
hansel and mcintyre
in after virtue mcintyre signals a
similar status to three virtues he says
that we need
justice courage and honesty these are in
a certain sense archetectonic
and he goes on and further works to
identify other dispensable virtues as
well
anselm's moral theory incorporates all
of these
and articulates the core virtues he has
justice courage humility
charity and and concord
the the other thing that i'll say very
quickly is in the section on thomas
start by talking about the ontological
argument people generally tend to think
that thomas just rejects it entirely
commentary on the psalms shows that
that's not the case he actually says
anselm is right
but there's a whole complicated picture
there
and then i go in and look at the
mystic conception of truth thomas very
clearly
took ansem as one of his main
interlocutors in working out this
conception of truth
that mcintyre then will see is very
important mcintyre wants to
you know see something like ansel was
talking about truth in action
truth in the will and all that so anselm
could in fact be a resource for that
thanks
we're actually at time but i'll take
whatever questions people want and
people can go if they want or you know
yeah
so a couple things that you said
in some confirms so like humility is
not as debasement of oneself but as the
right understanding of
self and relationship to uh to the holy
spirit
well and to other other beings sure yeah
exactly
and then the real happiness contrasted
with the world of justice yeah
and plus the will of justice being its
own object
and something that we have to have
divine some kind of divine age
to have uh so these once we've got it we
don't need divinate to keep it
when we've lost it we need divine aid to
restore it
okay sure um
when i hear these things i hear the
voice of the con
yes so i mean these are things and you
should also hear scopes too
that may be i'm less familiar by total
chance i read
cons on respect humility dignity
and the moral law for a conference i'm
going to next
yeah he says these things i mean is
there a connection there
no there's not a connection between
there's not a connection
in the sense that like red and salmon
you know
pirated these thoughts in or something
like that um
there is a connection in the sense that
there are structural similarities there
it's very interesting if you look at
anthem's moral theory as a whole there's
a question
what kind of moral theory is it clearly
it's if we use our categories that we
like to use like utilitarianism
no it's definitely not that could it be
a deontological theory
and some people have wanted to see it
that way
it's not like like [ __ ] because khan
focuses on the purely formal
and also you know kant doesn't have god
in the picture you know that's
necessity of interacting with god and
grace and all that sort of stuff
anselm's theory does end up being a
virtue ethics but it's got some very
clearly strong deontological
parts to it which should show us that
there is something to
deontology i mean i guess i'm thinking
below and deeper
than normal there's sort of
constructivist meta efforts right
so if you if you look at khan just
having is talking primarily about the
structure and pure reason like it seems
that's exactly what handsome was going
to if
he doesn't do any sort of analysis or
critique of pure practical reason by
itself that would be very foreign
isn't that what it would mean for
justice to be its own hunter
that you have to carry out a critique of
no i mean that's like a different way of
saying you've had a worldview yeah
although the will to justice
and the will to happiness are not when
the will of justice is actually
functioning the way
you want to it's going to integrate the
will to happiness within it all the
you know well-functioning human being as
opposed to a screwed up person like
me or you know maybe some of the other
people in the room
it will actually uh curb
and gradually modify the will to
happiness our basic you know affective
structures
so that we want the right things we take
pleasure in the right things
you know um because this question comes
up you know
especially not so much in relation
competent in relation to aquinas aquinas
is
you know saying well if you get your
basic desires right
and you actually understand what
happiness is it's kind of
easy street from from there and you're
not going to need something like a will
to justice along with that you're going
to will justly because you recognize
what the good for you is and all that
anselm is saying there's something
there's something else
we don't it's not just that we recognize
this
ultimately desirable object out there
and that's sufficiently motivating
we need something within us which
actually is going to turn to come from
that ontologically and makes it makes us
more whole in the process
so roundabout way of answering that
question i think
yeah when i think of anselm in the
context of virtues
i think of the fact that he defines free
will as an ability
like you mentioned which to me looks
like freedom of the will as an ability
free will is
is his ability to preserve uprightness
for its own sake right freedom of the
well yeah right so
i see him as sort of the beginning of
the
tradition that surveillance pinchers put
so much effort into
with the difference between freedom for
excellence
as opposed to freedom of indifference
because with anselm yeah i understand
you don't have
in as much as you are choosing to do the
wrong thing limiting
and losing freedom yeah the degree that
you do the right thing
freedom is maintained and expanded yeah
i mean he's not he's it's not like
anselm is
coming up with this all by himself
totally out of you know
yeah i'm not using that i guess
yeah it's bigger in there than i've seen
it anywhere previous
well augustine you know i mean i think
augustine
he he gives he gives ants on the run for
his money on this right
at least in that and you know i would
say to
some of the monastic fathers
this is something i think is deficient
in mcintyre's account
you read somebody like john cassian who
is not
really giving his own take on stuff but
presenting what he's learning from
not western fathers but egyptian and
syrian
monastic fathers they knew what the will
was
they they had some you know really
seriously i mean these guys thought
about this stuff they had some
serious insights into the relationship
between
you know grace freedom of will how we
can lose that
whether it was you know just
freedom to do whatever we want or
freedom to be directed towards
this other thing and anselm is getting
those guys in part because they read
them at the monastery
gregory erin gregory benedict's rule
actually recommends
reading these monastic fathers so hansel
is
hansel just doesn't cite anybody
it's a problem
yeah i just have a small technical point
but at some point when you were talking
about devices and virtues
you talked about thresholds yeah i think
a better term might be
continuum there's a continuum and then
there's a threshold at the end of that
continuum and then once you cross that
threshold you're in the other continuum
you know anselm does think that there's
certain points at which you pass from
justice to injustice it's not like
there's a you know
gray zone in between where um
now could be their way or something like
that and it's that way
with with the virtues and vices um i
should add too that he doesn't have a
versatilion conception of the light the
virtues
as being like in between two vices it's
a much more augustinian thing
where you know you got one one vice
virtue and
then sooner or later everything is
somewhere in that spectrum
there's you know at the one end of the
continuum you've got like
really solidly developed justice really
solidly
developed injustice that's what we
usually call virtues devices right
but the medieval is quite often we talk
about
lesser and lesser amounts of it so that
you're doing
you're doing unjust things
and you've crossed finally into the
threshold of being unjust
you know where you're you know you're
acting without fortitude
sooner or later you're you know you're
not able to stand up to things
you get angry there's a certain point at
which you cross and you're no longer
a patient person here right i guess i
was
sort of weighing that maybe more in the
er certainly in sense too because
yeah in aristotle devices and virtues
are also individual to the person in
their capacities
i mean yeah what's virtuous for one
person may not be purchased for a
different person
if you're in a different to a certain
degree well i mean there's some things
that are always going to be like you
know
off limits right but i mean
even you know if you think about the
exercise of
courage in a situation where you're
watching
if you're in a doc watching it and use
this in class a lot if you're at a doc
watching the drop-in kid
yeah and you know person a is a trained
lifeguard
person d doesn't know how to swim to
jump in and try and save the child
for person a that's kind of the virtuous
ordering courageous but maybe not
because they're a good swimmer yeah for
person b
for them to jump in
do something so you have two people in
identical circumstances
yeah but the virtuous action is
different action
let's try it by virtue of their
individual capacity
yeah they'll do something like that for
for i mean there's something like that
for a while
something like that for handsome too
yeah
just a small um on the idea of continuum
and
threshold and whatnot yeah um maybe
some virtues have a great area maybe um
for answering you're saying i'm just i'm
i'm saying it's a subject india
yeah it's a substance you've got say
truthfulness right and you've got
someone who just tells wild vibes right
and someone who just doesn't say the
true thing when they often have have
yeah you know it's not like they're
lying it's not like they're not
you know if this what do you say that
exactly become
this sort of a not a gray area maybe but
it's a it's a funky area well
they're not vicious but they're not
virtual it's a great time to make
distinctions
you know they're not they're not um
they're not virtuous or vicious in the
full strict sense i would say but they
they could answer them they would be you
know
see when we think in aristotelian sense
aerosol says
that you know some people are virtuous
and some people are vicious and one of
the good things about virtue ethics is
you don't have to be virtuous or vicious
in order to be evaluated as doing good
or bad
actions because you can say well that's
an unjust action
because that's the kind of thing unjust
people do you know
like that action was vicious yeah you're
not vicious necessarily
you're not yet yeah yeah but but you
better watch
if you see anything like continents and
incoming stages between
he doesn't talk in those in those terms
could we
analogize between those uh yeah i think
we could
because when we free answer when we do
injustice
we're not just doing something that's
that's wrong and you know against some
sort of standard
we're doing something that fundamentally
disorders our soul and makes it tougher
the next time around for us to do
the right thing and sometimes even
recognize it as the right thing
so it can produce that that um
you know lack of self-control that
across you is
that ties in with you know the
conception of freedom freedom to be able
to actually
do what we ought to be doing to align
ourselves with
with what we know is right um
yeah and a certain sense theocratic is
less free right than the
self-control person not as free as the
virtuous person
but uh is there going to be a chapter on
what you're writing also about the
relationship between
say the work of the holy spirit in one's
life and virtue of devices
when you read the other theological
works like per days yeah
virgin
yeah it's kind of it's i don't want to
say it's bracketed out of on
not freedom of choice but it's not as
prevalent well it's just he hasn't come
in yet
you know he says he does talk about the
need to have grace in order to restore
justice that's that's lacking in the
will and he also tells us you know god
um god himself can't take away justice
in the will once you've got it
only you can throw it away
anselm says in the day concordia that
the ways of grace
are so many and so manifold that i'm not
going to try to explain all of them
you know and he never does some sort of
systematic analysis
but yeah it'll fit in there because
anselm also sees
two other things to say about that so so
anselm thinks that we have been given as
part of our
our human nature a lot of the stuff that
we need in order to behave properly
and to get ourselves moving on the right
track
those also do involve cooperation with
grace oftentimes we don't see that as
operation of grace the other thing that
he says that's really important
is that we receive grace not just like
you know directly from god
but through the mediation of other
people
and you can look at the same thing in
two different ways so let's say
you help me out right you're there
providentially to give me
the advice that i need at the right time
that would actually like help me be
restored to justice
because i'm not going to be so much of a
schmuck right and
um now you're doing that out of your own
free will
because you're cooperating with the
grace that god has given you let's say
you're a totally just guy you know
and uh by hypothesis right and uh
so you're doing it because you're
actually making a choice on your part to
use the good that you have
and to retain it to keep maintain the
world of justice part of that is is
helping me out right
so from one perspective it's wholly you
from the other perspective well where
did you get all that stuff from
from god so god's grace is coming to me
for me to cooperate with via you
then does that does that take away your
freedom in any degree no
we're what we're called to for for
hansel is this community in which
our will and the divine will and
everybody else's will is harmonized with
each other
and we're we're able to share in this
complete communion
you know um very different from where we
are
very different from where anselm was
most of the time
uh but he sketches that in the process
towards it towards the end
yeah yeah kind of
only unless less less abstract
yeah yeah i don't know if i want to live
in god's kingdom events
you wanted to talk about stopping your
questions or
or can i draw this jump solos and you
can ask me afterwards
yourself you're interested in you know
french debates
all in the medieval philosophy that oh i
did a lot of
subject matter in the case of bandsaw
i've been interested in anselm
for about 15 years so that amputates the
christian philosophy debate stuff